it was a message
that will overcome the cruelty and
brutality
of this unjust war
when pope john paul
brought that message in 1979
the soviet union ruled with an iron fist
behind an iron curtain
then a year later
the solidarity movement
took hold in poland
well i know he couldn't be here tonight
we're all grateful
in america and around the world for
liquelenca
[Applause]
reminds me of that phrase
from philosopher kierkegaard
faith
sees best in the dark
they were dark moments
ten years later the soviet union
collapsed
and poland
and central and eastern europe
would soon be free
nothing about that battle for freedom
was simple or easy
it was a long painful slog
fought over not days and months but
years and decades
but we emerged anew
in the great battle for freedom
a battle between democracy and autocracy
between liberty and repression
between a rules-based order
and one governed
by brute force
in this battle
we need to be clear-eyed
this battle will not be won
in days
or months either
we need to steal ourselves
of a long fight ahead
mr president mr prime minister mr mayor
members of the parliament distinguished
guests
and the people of poland
and i suspect some people
of ukraine that are here
we are
we are gathered here at the royal castle
in this city that holds a sacred place
in the history of not only
of europe
but humankind's unending search for
freedom
for generations
warsaw has stood
where liberty has been challenged and
liberty has prevailed
in fact
it was here in warsaw
when a young refugee who fled her home
country from czechoslovakia was under
soviet domination came back to speak
and stand in solidarity with dissonance
her name was madeleine colbert albright
she became
one of the most ardent supporters of the
democracy in the world she was a friend
with whom i served
america's first woman secretary of state
she passed away three days ago
she fought her whole life
for central democratic principles
and now
in the perennial struggle for democracy
and freedom
ukraine and his people
are on the front lines
fighting to save their nation
and their brave resistance is part of a
larger fight
for an essential
democratic principles that unite all
free people the rule of law
fair and free elections
the freedom to speak
to right and to assemble
the freedom to worship as one chooses
freedom of the press these principles
are essential in a free society
but they have always
they have always been under siege
they've always been in battle
every generation has had to defeat
democracy's moral foes
that's the way the world
for the world is imperfect as we know
where the appetites and ambitions of a
few
forever seek to dominate the lives and
liberty of many
my message to the people of ukraine
is the message i delivered today to
ukraine's foreign minister and defense
minister who i believe are here tonight
we stand with you period
today's fighting key with metropolitan
car key
of the latest battle in a long struggle
hungary 1956
poland
1956 and then again
1981 czechoslovakia in 1968
soviet tanks
crushed democratic uprisings
but the resistance continued
until finally
in 1989 the berlin wall and all the
walls of soviet domination they fell
they fell
and the people prevailed
[Applause]
but the battle for democracy could not
conclude
and did not conclude with the end of the
cold war
over the last 30 years the forces of
autocracy
have revived all across the globe
its hallmarks are familiar ones
contempt for the rule of law
contempt for democratic freedom
contempt for the truth itself
today
russia has strangled democracy
has sought to do so elsewhere not only
in his homeland
under false claims of ethnic solidarity
has invalidated neighboring nations
putin has the gall
to say he's denotifying ukraine
it's a lie
it's just cynical he knows that
and it's also obscene
president zielinski
was democratically elected
he's jewish his father's family was
wiped out in the nazi holocaust
and putin
has the audacity like all our autocrats
before him
to believe that might will make right
my own country
a former president named abraham lincoln
voiced the opposing spirit
to save our union in the midst of the
civil war
he said let us have faith that right
makes might
right makes might
today
let us have that faith again
let us resolve to put the strength of
democracies into action to thwart the
denials of the designs of autocracy
let us remember that the test of this
moment
is the test of all time
the kremlin wants to portray nato
enlargement as an imperial project
aimed at destabilizing russia
nothing is further from the truth
nato is a defensive alliance
it has never sought the demise
of russia
in the lead-up to the current crisis
the united states and nato worked for
months
to engage russia to avert war
i met with in person talked to him many
times on the phone
time and again
we offer real diplomacy
and concrete proposals to strengthen
european security enhance transparency
build confidence on all sides
but putin and russia meant each of the
proposals with disinterested
in any negotiation
with lies and ultimatums
russia was bent on violence from the
start
i know not all of you believed me and us
when we kept saying they are going to
cross the border they are going to
attack
repeatedly
he asserted we had no interest in war
guaranteed
he would not move
repeatedly
saying he would not invade ukraine
repeatedly
saying russian troops along the border
were there for training all 180 000 of
them
there's simply no justification
or provocation
for russia's choice of war
it's an example one of the oldest human
impulses
using bruce force and disinformation
to satisfy a craving for absolute power
and control
it's nothing less than a direct
challenge
to the rule-based international order
established since the end of world war
ii
and it threatens
to return to decades of war
that ravaged europe
before the international rule-based
order was put in place
we can not go back to that we cannot
the gravity of the threat
is why the response of the west
has been so swift and so powerful
and so unified unprecedented and
overwhelming
swift and punishing cost
are the only things going to get russia
to change its course
within days of his invasion the west has
moved jointly with sanctions to damage
russia's economy
russia's central bank
is now blocked from global financial
system denying kremlin's access to the
war fund that's stashed around the globe
we've aimed at the heart of russia's
economy
by stopping the imports of russian
energy to the united states
to date
the united states has sanctioned 140
russian oligarchs and their family
members seizing their ill-begotten gangs
their yachts their luxury apartments
their mansions
we've sanctioned more than 400 russian
government officials including
key architects of this war
these officials and oligarchs
have reaped enormous benefit
from the corruption
connected to the kremlin
and now
they have to share in the pain
the private sector is acting as well
over 400
private multinational companies have
pulled out of doing business in russia
left russia completely from oil
companies to mcdonald's
as a result
of these unprecedented sanctions
the ruble almost is immediately reduced
to rubble
the russian economy
that's true by the way
it takes about 200 rubles to equal one
dollar
the economy is on track to be cut in
half
in the coming years
it was ranked russian economy was ranked
the 11th biggest economy in the world
before this evasion invasion
it will soon not even rank among the top
20 in the world
taken together
[Applause]
these economic sanctions a new kind of
economic type statecraft with the power
to inflict damage
that rivals military might these
international sanctions are sapping
russian strength
its ability to replenish its military
and its ability its ability to project
power
and it is putin
it is vladimir putin who is to blame
period at the same time
alongside these economic sanctions
the western world has come together to
provide
for the people of ukraine
with incredible levels of military
economic humanitarian assistance
in the years before the invasion we
america had sent over 650 million
dollars
before they crossed the border in
weapons of ukraine including anti-air
and anti-armor equipment since the
invasion
america has committed another
1.35 billion dollars in weapons and
ammunition
and thanks to the courage and bravery of
the ukrainian people
the equipment we've sent and our
colleagues have sent have been used to
devastating effect to defend ukrainian
land and airspace
our allies and partners have stepped up
as well
but as i've made clear
america forces are in europe
not in europe to engage in conflict with
russian forces american forces
are here to defend nato allies yesterday
i met with the troops that are serving
alongside our polish allies to bolster
nato's front-line defenses
the reason we wanted to make clear
is their movement
on ukraine
don't even think
about
moving on one single inch of nato
territory
we have sacred obligations
we have a sacred obligation under
article 5 to defend each and every inch
of nato territory
for the full force of our collective
power
and earlier today
i visit your national stadium where
thousands of ukrainian refugees are now
trying to answer
the toughest questions a human can ask
my god what's going to happen to me
what's going to happen to my family
i saw tears in many of the mother's eyes
as i embraced them
their young children were young children
not sure whether to smile
or cry
one little girl said
mr president she spoke a little english
if my brother and my daddy are they
going to be okay
will i see them again
without their husbands their fathers
many cases their brothers and sisters
who stayed back to fight for their
country
i didn't have to speak the language or
understand the language
to feel the emotion
in their eyes
where they gripped my hand
little kids hung onto my leg
praying
for the desperate hope
that all this is temporary
apprehension
that they may be perhaps forever away
from their homes
almost a debilitating sadness
that this is happening all over again
but it was also struck
by the generosity
of the people of warsaw for that matter
all the polish people
for the depths of their compassion
their willingness to reach out
opening their hearts
say to the mayor and the parent to open
their hearts and their homes
simply to help
i also want to thank my friend the great
american chef
jose andres and his team their help
feeling though feeding those who are
yearning to be free
but helping these refugees is not
something poland or any other nation
should carry alone
all the world democracies have a
responsibility to help all of them and
the people of ukraine can count on the
united states to meet its responsibility
i've announced two days ago we will
welcome a hundred thousand ukrainian
refugees we already have eight thousand
a week coming to the united states of
other nationalities
will provide nearly 300 million
humanitarian assistance
providing tens of thousands of tons of
food water medicine and other basic
supplies
in brussels
i announced the united states prepared
to provide more than one billion dollars
in additional humanitarian aid
the world food program
told us despite significant obstacles
at least some relief
is getting to major cities in ukraine
but not metropole
now it's going to be
not mariopol
because russian forces are blocking
relief supplies
but will not cease our efforts
get humanitarian relief wherever it is
needed in ukraine and for the people
who've made it out of ukraine
notwithstanding the brutality of
vladimir putin but to be no doubt
that this war has already been a
strategic failure for russia already
[Applause]
having lost children myself i know
that's no solace to the people
lost family
but he putin
thought ukrainians would roll over and
not fight
not much of a student of history
instead russian forces have met their
match with brave and stiff ukrainian
resistance
rather than breaking ukrainian resolve
russia's brutal tactics have
strengthened the resolve
rather than driving nato apart the west
is now stronger and more united than it
has ever been
russia wanted
less of a nato presence
on his border but now he has a stronger
presence a larger presence with over a
hundred thousand american troops here
along with all the other members of nato
in fact
russia has managed to cause something
i'm sure he never intended
the democracies of the world are
revitalized with purpose and unity found
in
months
that we've once taken years to
accomplish
it's not only
russia's actions in ukraine that are
reminding us of democracy's blessing
it's our own country
his own country the kremlin is jailing
protesters
two hundred thousand people have
allegedly already left
there's a brain drain leaving
russia
shutting down independent news
state media is all propaganda
blocking the image of civilian targets
mass graves starvation tactics
of the russian forces in ukraine
is any wonder as i said that 200 000
russians
have already left their country in one
month
a remarkable brain dam
in such a short period of time
which brings me to my message to the
russian people
i've worked with russian leaders for
decades
i sat across a negotiating table going
all the way back to soviet premier
lexicocigan to talk arms control at the
height of the cold war
i've always spoken directly and honestly
to you the russian people
let me say this if you're able to listen
you the russian people are not our enemy
i refuse to believe that you welcome the
killing of innocent children and
grandparents
or that you accept hospitals schools
maternity wards and for god's sake being
pummeled with russian missiles and bombs
or cities being surrounded so that
civilians cannot flee
supplies cut off
and attempting to starve ukrainians into
submissions
millions of families
are being driven from their homes
including half
of all ukraine's children
these are not the actions of a great
nation
of all people you the russian people
as well as all people across europe
still have the memory of being in a
similar situation
in the late 30s and 40s
situation in world war ii
still fresh in the minds of many
grandparents
in the
region whatever your generation
experienced
whether it experienced a siege of
leningrad
or heard about it from your parents and
grandparents train stations overflowing
with terrified families fleeing their
homes nights sheltering in basements and
sellers mourning sitting through the
rubble in your homes these are not
memories of the past not anymore
because exactly what the russian army
is doing in ukraine right now
march 26 2020
just days before
we're at the 21st you were a 21st
century nation
with hopes and dreams that people all
over the world have for themselves and
their family now
vladimir putin's aggression have cut you
the russian people off from the rest of
the world
and it's taking russia
back to the 19th century
this is not who you are
this is not the future reserve you
deserve for your families
and your children
i'm telling you the truth
this war is not worthy of you the
russian people
putin can and must end this war
the american people will stand with you
and the brave citizens of ukraine
who want peace
my message to the rest of europe
this new battle for freedom has already
made a few things crystal clear
first europe must end its dependence on
russian fossil fuels
and we the united states will help
that's why i just yesterday in brussels
and i announced the plan with the
president the european commission
to get europe through the immediate
energy crisis
over the long term
as a matter of economic security and
national security for the survivability
of the planet
we all need to move as quickly as
possible to clean renewable energy
and we'll work together to help get that
done
so that the days of any nation
being subject to the whims of a tyrant
for its energy needs are over they must
end they must end
and second
we have to fight the corruption
coming from the kremlin
to give the russian people a fair chance
and finally most urgently we maintain
absolute unity we must among the world's
democracies it's not enough to speak
with rhetorical flourish
of ennobling words of democracy of
freedom equality and liberty
all of us including here in poland
must do the hard work of democracy each
and every day my country as well that's
why
that's why
i came to europe again this week
with a clear and determined message
for nato
for the g7 for the european union
for all freedom-loving nations
we must commit now
to be in this fight for the long haul we
must remain unified today and tomorrow
and the day after and for the years and
decades to come it will not be easy
there will be cost
but it's a price we have to pay because
the darkness that drives autocracy is
ultimately no match
for the flame of liberty that lights the
souls of free people everywhere
time and again
history shows that it's from the darkest
moments that the greatest progress
follows
and history shows
this is the task of our time
the task of this generation
let's remember the hammer blow that
brought down the berlin wall
the might that lifted the iron curtain
were not the words of a single leader
it was the people of europe
who for decades
fought to free themselves their sheer
bravery opened the border between
austria and hungary
for the pan-european picnic
they joined hands for the baltic way
they stood for solidarity here in poland
and together
it was an unmistakable and undeniable
force of the people
that the soviet union could not
withstand
and we're seeing it once again today
with a brave human ukrainian people
showing that their power of many is
greater than the will of any one
dictator
so in this hour
let the words of pope john paul born as
brightly today
never ever give up hope
never doubt
never tire never become discouraged
be not afraid
a dictator
bent on rebuilding an empire will never
erase the people's love for liberty
brutality will never
grind down their will to be free
ukraine will never be a victory for
russia
for free people refused to live in a
world of hopelessness and darkness we
will have a different future a brighter
future rooted in democracy and principle
hope and light
of decency and dignity of freedom and
possibilities
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power
god bless you all and may god defend our
freedom and may god protect our troops
thank you for your patience
thank you
thank you
thank you